اوقفت شركات تكنولوجيه تايوانيه اعمالها
مع ايران وسط تحقيق فيما اذا كانت قد
انتهكت العقوبات الدوليه حيث تكثف
الولايات المتحده تدقيقها في انتاج ايران
العسكري وتورطها في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وبحسب تقرير دهيله الامريكيه
اوقفت شركه ايتن انترناشونال قبول الطلبات
من ايران ومنع التصديره منتجاتها الى
البلاد بعد المخاوف التي اثرتها منظمه
متحدون ضد ايران نوويه وتشير مخاوف
المنظمه واستجابه لشركه ايتن الى مشكله
اكبر حيث يبدو ان ايران تبحث عن المواد
اللازمه لبرنامج الطائرات بدون طيار على
الرغم من الجهود التي تبذلها الولايات
المتحده واوروبا لعزل النظام بالعقوبه كما
تشمل المخاوف من ان منتجات ايتن يتم
شرائها من قبل شركات تكنولوجيا المعلومات
الايرانيه كمبيوتر
مع الحرس الثوري الاسلامي الايراني مما
وضع الشركه امام انتهاكات محتمله للعقبات
لك
يا احمد